the jurogan experience have you talked
to chappelle about uh all the [ __ ] he
got from yeah a little bit we texted
back and forth it's you know he's just
you know riding out the storm he's not a
homophobic or transphobic person he
makes fun of himself
there's a bit in that special about him
getting molested and jerking off in a
man's face
yeah i mean this is or coming in a man's
face that look
it's
fun it's just making jokes that doesn't
mean hate this is the problem with today
if you
don't have an enemy you make an enemy
and this is a real problem with people
we we would look for things
like if there's people that really hated
you and they were the enemy people that
just joked around about stuff wouldn't
be thought of as the enemy it's like and
as the level of people truly hate you
drops
you start looking for equilibrium and
what you're upset about and so now
you're more upset about jokes now
silence is violence and now you know you
can't just be this you have to be that
and it becomes this like weird control
level
where what people start to conflate you
start when you start equating jokes with
like real feelings well you they're
they're they're not the same thing well
i don't think that's what it is i think
they're trying to put different
individuals or groups on a pedestal and
kind of make them sacred and you have
someone comes along and knocks them off
that pedal so all of a sudden you're
trying to undo what i'm trying to do
which is to make this person holy and
now you are my enemy because your agenda
is the opposite of mine fully agree i
was getting too sorry okay no no it's
okay you're right though 100
but it's these these ideas that that you
can't make fun of are dangerous they're
not good for anybody they're not good
for the people who hold those ideas
whether it's about who you are or what
you do
the idea that no fun can be had about
any of this is crazy because the idea is
that then all fun is done maliciously
and out of hate and we know as friends
that is just not true
all my fun is malicious it's well it's
also funny
if you and i were [ __ ] with each
other and we're saying ridiculous [ __ ]
to each other we would
both be smiling
this is what rose battle's all about my
friend brian moses this is what a lot of
what kill tony's about like it's fun
there's fun in making fun of each other
and we have to accept that yeah and then
i need to know your real feelings about
gay people your real feelings about
trans people your real feelings about
all religions and all races and all
ethnicities but we got to be able to
joke around about each other and if you
get down to dave chappelle's real
feelings
he's a lovely person he's one of the
nicest people i've ever met in my life
he loves everybody he he's not a hateful
soul he's beyond jealous
he's just
a guy who loves this art form
called stand up comedy and he tries to
do his best navigating through this
world of talking [ __ ] about things and
saying outrageous things that get huge
laughs or
placating really sensitive groups that
feel like they're in a protected class
and then the other people that pile onto
that that also feel like this is a
protected class and they equate any
jokes with hate
and this is where they're wrong like i'm
telling you that dave chappelle does not
hate anyone or anything but he's not
that person he's his jokes are just that
they're just jokes and if you really pay
attention to what he's saying
whether you agree with him or not in
some of his jokes like whether or not
they're funny just really pay attention
to the overall message it is in no way
transphobic it's just not but this is a
way for low status people to try to
compete with dave and try to get on his
level because if i'm some kind of rando
journalist and i take down dave
chappelle or joe rogan or somebody else
this elevates my status in my rank and
takes him down a peg and that's useful
you're right from an evolutionary point
of view you're you're absolutely right
you can't can't be denied if you're a
person and you're looking up at a guy
like dave chappelle he's at the highest
of high levels right you have to you
know you you have to also acquit you
have to equate that in anything you you
think about when you think about a guy
like dave chappelle
but then you also have to realize that
the problem is in
listening to everybody
you're going to get a certain group of
people that want people to not be able
to work anymore they want to like stop
you they want to pull things down they
want to change like what's available you
don't have to like it like here's the
thing about dave chappelle
look he's clearly
the most popular comedian on planet
earth right he's number one
he he's clearly one of the greatest
comedians that's ever lived clearly
so
obviously a lot of [ __ ] people like
him and what you want is people did not
have access to him right when you have
options
you don't have to like it but if you
want netflix to take it down and you say
it's hateful
this is this is an incorrect way to do
this if you want to make your own
special about what was wrong with dave
chappelle's going on youtube with your
monologue like keith yeah yeah exactly
go for it and good luck to you and maybe
you'll have a point
that that person that you're criticizing
could take into consideration and go
maybe i could do better at this because
if something does bother you if someone
says something ridiculous about you
it doesn't make any sense it doesn't
have any effect on you the things that
bother people is things that are at
least slightly accurate but i think this
just kind of speaks to what we're
talking about earlier how they're trying
to have their be in the same way how
intentionally or not it's trying to push
everyone to be an amazon or a walmart
customer they are trying to have
everyone only consume media through
pre-approved sources right that's a
problem if you're not reading the new
york times or cnn or the wall street or
the washington post or whatever
that means you're doing something wrong
so this is what they're doing that
process of elimination by trying to
funnel people into certain outlets that
they themselves can control and that
creates uniformity and cohesion among
the population i think the problem is
you create a journalistic version of the
streisand effect
i think that's the problem that's
encouraging people to watch chappelle
yeah it's encouraging for sure that
special's giant yeah oh yeah and all the
controversy has only been good and then
the controversy is [ __ ] because it's
not like he's howard stern back in the
day well it's not only that what he's
saying in this he's telling about he's
telling a story about a real person that
he was close with that that died that
became friends with him through comedy
there's a whole story to it i don't want
to give it up because i think you should
watch it special
i toured with dave we did a lot of shows
together it's
this is his story
that he had about this person that he
loved that died it's not a it's not a
transphobic story but there's jokes in
there and in those jokes he's poking fun
at everything including himself
i mean this is a part of his acts part
of any comics act like there's it's
there's a lot of it that's just designed
to be funny while he's telling a story
that's one of the things that dave does
so well he's like he tells these stories
and he figures out a way to get his
point across while being really funny
but when you're going to be really funny
you're going to make fun of yourself
you're going to make fun of other people
you're going to make fun of everything
but that's but that doesn't equal hate
and that's not how men demonstrate
camaraderie yeah coming from brooklyn
you have the jewish guy the italian guy
you have the puerto rican guy you have
the black guy everyone's busting each
other's chops and that's how you
symbolize that you're comfortable with
each other yes i'm safe with you by
saying things that would get me in
trouble in other contexts and i trust
you enough to know that you're not going
to use that in a bad way that we're all
bros here watch the entire episode for
free only on spotify